IT ACROSS THE FINISH LINE SHE IS
NOT QUITE READY TO SAY YES TO
BIDEN'S BUILD BACK BETTER PLAN.
YOU HAVE MET DIRECTLY WITH THE
PRESIDENT PERHAPS MORE THAN ANY
OTHER SENATOR IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY MAYBE ASIDE FROM JOE
MANCHIN.
WHAT LESSONS HAVE YOU LEARNED?
WHAT KIND OF NEGOTIATOR IS THE
PRESIDENT?
IS IT HARD FOR YOU TO TELL THE
PRESIDENT, NO, I CAN'T DO THAT?
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN SERVED IN THE
SENATE FOR A LONG TIME SO HE
KNOWS HOW NEGOTIATIONS WORK.
HE ALSO DURING THIS PROCESS
CALLED ME REPEATEDLY AND ASKED
ME TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
SENATOR ROB PORTMAN AND OTHERS
IN THE G 10 TO FIND THIS
BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT.
AND SHOWED A REAL COMMITMENT TO
WANTING THIS BIPARTISAN
ACHIEVEMENT, WHICH WE HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED.
I THINK THE BIG CHALLENGE IN
FRONT OF US IS FOR US TO ALL
WORK TOGETHER IN AN ACCOUNTABLE
AND TRANSPARENT WAY TO ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT THIS LAW.
>> Reporter: SCHUMER HAS SAID HE
WANTS TO VOTE ON BUILD BACK
BETTER THE BROADER SOCIAL SAFETY
NET BILL BEFORE CHRISTMAS BREAK.
ARE YOU PREPARED TO VOTE YES
WHEN THAT COMES TO THE FLOOR?
>> I DON'T SET THE SCHEDULE FOR
THE SENATE FLOOR.
I AM ALWAYS PREPARED TO VOTE.
AND TO VOTE FOR WHAT IS RIGHT
FOR THE INTERESTS OF ARIZONA.
I PERSONALLY BELIEVE THAT THE
BEST WAY TO CREATE LEGISLATION
IS TO BE THOUGHTFUL AND CAREFUL
SO WE'RE CRAFTING LEGISLATION
THAT TRULY REPRESENTS THE
INTERESTS WE WANT TO ACHIEVE AND
CREATES A BENEFIT AND HELPS
PEOPLE ALL ACROSS ARIZONA AND
THE COUNTRY.
THAT IS WHAT I'M WORKING ON
RIGHT NOW.
>> IT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE YOU ARE
QUITE A YES YET ON THE VERSION
THAT JUST PASSED THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
WHAT CHANGES DO YOU WANT TO
MAKE?
>> FOLKS KNOW I DON'T NEGOTIATE
IN THE PRESS SO I AM NOT GOING
TO DO THAT WITH YOU.
>> Reporter: I KNOW ONE THING
YOU MADE CLEAR VERY EARLY IN THE
NEGOTIATION WITH THE PRESIDENT
AND YOUR MAJORITY LEADER WAS
THAT YOU WERE NOT GOING TO
SUPPORT RAISING THE CORPORATE
TAX RATE UP A SINGLE POINT.
DID YOU FEEL LIKE AT ANY POINT
THEY WEREN'T TAKING YOUR
COMMENTS SERIOUSLY GIVEN THE
FACT THAT THEY WERE PROMISING
FOR A LONG TIME THIS WAS GOING
TO BE PART OF THE BILL?
>> I DON'T SPEND MUCH TIME
THINKING ABOUT WHAT OTHER PEOPLE
ARE SAYING PUBLICLY.
WHAT I REALLY WANT TO FOCUS ON
IS HOW TO GET TO A SOLUTION AND
SOLVE A PROBLEM THAT MATTERS TO
EVERY DAY FOLKS IN ARIZONA.
PEOPLE BACK HOME IN ARIZONA KNOW
THAT I AM COMMITTED TO ENSURING
ANY LEGISLATION WE PASS RETAINS
AMERICA'S COMPETITIVENESS.
SO I WON'T SUPPORT ANY
LEGISLATION THAT INCREASES
BURDENS ON ARIZONANS OR AMERICAN
BUSINESSES AND DECREASES OUR
ABILITY TO COMPETE DOMESTICALLY
OR GLOBALLY.
I WANT TO BE SURE IF WE CRAFT
LEGISLATION WE DO IT IN A LEAN
AND EFFICIENT WAY THAT IS
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE AND DOESN'T
IMPACT THINGS LIKE INFLATION OR
MAKE OUR BUSINESSES LESS
COMPETITIVE.
>> SO YOU HAVE BEEN CRITICIZED
FROM PROGRESSIVES WHO SAY YOU'RE
STANDING IN THE WAY OF WHAT
WE'VE BEEN CAMPAIGNING ON FOR
YEARS WHETHER THAT IS REPEALING
THE 2017 TAX CUTS, WHETHER THAT
IS CHANGING VOTING RIGHTS LAWS.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO PROGRESSIVES
BACK HOME WHO ARE DISAPPOINTED
IN THE JOB YOU ARE DOING HERE?
>> WELL, I AM SERVING THE EXACT
WAY I HAVE CAMPAIGNED ON OVER
THE LAST NEAR DECADE I HAVE
SERVED IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
WHEN I RAN FOR THE UNITED STATES
SENATE IN 2018 I TOLD THE FOLKS
OF ARIZONA WHAT I WOULD DO.
THAT I WOULD COME TO THE SENATE,
TRY TO FIND BIPARTISAN
SOLUTIONS, BE AN INDEPENDENT
VOICE FOR ARIZONA, AND ALWAYS
PUT EVERY DAY PEOPLE IN ARIZONA
FIRST.
I WOULD SAY THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT
I'M DOING.
>> ONE OF THE WAYS YOU NEGOTIATE
IN TALKING WITH YOUR COLLEAGUES
IS YOU ARE PRETTY FORTHCOMING ON
WHERE YOU STAND ON SOMETHING.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE CORPORATE
TAX RATE.
WHY DO YOU THINK IT IS THAT YOUR
LEADERSHIP SOMETIMES OVER
PROMISES?
DO YOU THINK THAT IS A PROBLEM
FOR VOTERS AND FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
>> I CAN ONLY SPEAK FOR MYSELF
BUT WHAT I CAN SAY IS THIS.
I WOULD NEVER PROMISE SOMETHING
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT I
CAN'T DELIVER.
I THINK IT IS NOT RESPONSIBLE
FOR ELECTED LEADERS TO DO THAT.
THE CONCERN I HAVE IS THAT,
FIRST, IT'S NOT VERY HONEST.
SO YOU SHOULD JUST BE HONEST.
THAT IS SOMETHING MY PARENTS
TAUGHT ME WHEN I WAS VERY YOUNG.
IT STUCK.
>> Reporter: SOME OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES, PROGRESSIVES, THINK
YOU'RE KIND OF AN ENIGMA.
THEY'RE NOT SURE WHERE YOU STAND
ON ANY ONE ISSUE WHILE YOU'RE IN
THE MIDDLE OF A NEGOTIATION.
DO YOU THINK THAT IS A FAIR
CRITICISM OF YOU?
>> I THINK I AM VERY DIRECT AND
I AM VERY UPFRONT WHEN I TALK TO
FOLKS ABOUT WHAT I BELIEVE IN,
WHAT I CAN SUPPORT AND WHAT I
CAN'T SUPPORT.
SO I THINK THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE
WHO JUST DON'T LIKE WHAT THEY'RE
HEARING AND MAYBE THEY USE OTHER
TERMS TO DESCRIBE IT BUT FOLKS
IN ARIZONA KNOW THAT I HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN A STRAIGHT SHOOTER
AND ALWAYS WILL BE.
>> WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO VOTE
WITH DEMOCRATS TO HOLD UP THE
PRESIDENT'S MANDATES?
>> I AM NOT GOING TO TELL YOU
THOSE THINGS.
WHAT I WILL DO IS MAKE SURE I
VOTE IN THE INTEREST OF
ARIZONANS.
FOLKS IN ARIZONA KNOW I AM A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS VAC.
I ENCOURAGE ALL ARIZONANS TO G